bei den mixed teilchen war es genau so
schon monate im voraus kündigte sich die
sensationelle entdeckung an
durch erste schwache trends in den daten
und auch jetzt befinden sich die
forschungsteams am cern nahe genf wieder
in so einer phase des bangens und
hoffens denn es gibt immer mehr hinweise
auf ein neues spektakuläres teilchen die
entsprechenden daten stammen vom lhc b
das ist eines der vier großen
experimente am teilchenbeschleuniger
large hadron collider lhc alles über die
neue spur eines unbekannten teilchens
jetzt hier bei pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen und wieder einmal
herzlichen dank für diesen spannenden
themen vorschlag aus eurer whatsapp
community das lhc experimente am
teilchenbeschleuniger lhc in genf ist
spezialisiert auf die beobachtung von
seltenen teilchen zerfallen
das b hinter lhc steht übrigens für
beauty also lhc large hadron collider
beauty der entsprechende detector des
experiments ist auf den nachweis der
sogenannten b mesonen die zur klasse der
hadronen gehören und eine negative
elemental ladung haben getrimmt denn
diese enthalten die beauty quarks die
untersucht werden sollen im
standardmodell der teilchenphysik bilden
quax die elementaren bestandteile aus
den protonen und neutronen aufgebaut
sind das besondere an dem beauty drohnen
ist dass sie bis zu zwei zentimeter weit
im detektor fliegen ehe sie in weitere
teilchen zerfallen
im lcb detector finden in jeder sekunde
10 millionen proton proton kollisionen
stadt eine aufzeichnung dieser
zahlreichen ereignisse auf so einen
datenträger ist nicht möglich denn das
gibt der speicherplatz einfach nicht her
und so wird in echtzeit entschieden
welches ereignis interessant ist dass
übernimmt ein sogenanntes trigger system
das durch zwei filter schritte
herausfinden kann ob ein ereignis ein
beauty h drohen enthält und das
analysiert werden sollte konkret ist der
led sektor ein vorwärts spektrometer auf
20 metern entlang des stahlrohr sind
seine sub detektoren aufgebaut seine
komponenten befinden sich nicht zwiebel
artig um den koalitions punkt herum
sondern sind auf der einen seite des
wechsel wirkungs punktes um das
stahlrohr angeordnet und zwar
kegelförmig am konsums punkt befindet
sich der erste sup detektor vom lhc b
die anderen folgen auf einer länge von
20 metern
neben seiner länge von
rund 20 metern ist der sektor 13 meter
breit und zehn meter hoch an dem
experiment sind knapp 1200
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
aus 16 ländern beteiligt unter anderem
aus drei institutionen aus deutschland
im großen und ganzen geht es hier um
große fragen der physik und des lebens
um materie und antimaterie unser
universum besteht ja hauptsächlich aus
materie doch wie kann das sein
schließlich gehen wir davon aus dass
eigentlich beim urknall antimaterie
materie in derselben menge erzeugt
worden sein müsste aber ist nicht so
jetzt wurden jedenfalls einige
datensätze durch das lhc b experiment
gewonnen die auf spektakuläre
erkenntnisse hoffen lassen denn als die
forschungsteams den zerfall der hadronen
untersucht hatten gab es abweichungen
zum standardmodell und das bildet die
säulen für die gesamte teilchenphysik
schon jetzt gibt es vage vermutungen was
hinter den abweichungen stecken könnte
ist es vielleicht endlich die existenz
der laptops die man damit nachweisen
kann in der theorie wurden sie schon in
den 80er jahren vorhergesagt doch bis
heute konnte man sie in der praxis nicht
nachweisen
falls das geschehen würde wäre dies eine
revolution in der physik laptops sollen
nämlich quarks also die atomkerne der
materie elektronen also leichte teilchen
umwandeln können elektronen gehörten
beispielsweise zu den lep ton genau wie
das mühen und das teilchen doch solch
eine umwandlung von quarks in der ton
ist nach dem standardmodell eigentlich
gar nicht möglich
bisher gibt es einfach keine verbindung
zwischen quarks und elektronen eine neue
physik müsste dann also her
ihr seht also wie spektakulär das ganze
ist und tatsächlich würde der beweis
dass bisher noch nicht entdeckten lab
quax eine große ungeklärte frage
beantworten warum ist der wert der
negativen ladung eines elektrons genauso
groß wie die positive elektrische ladung
eines protons das aus drei quarks
besteht endlich würde man dann durch die
entdeckung der laptop quax auch ein
stück weit die so lange erwünschte
supersymmetrie kurz susi untermauern
können die theorie dass es zu jedem
teilchen ein zweites ja symmetrisches
teilchen gibt und sie ineinander
umwandeln
doch nicht alle forschungsteams sind
optimistisch dass die ente
des laptops durch das rcb experten kurz
bevor steht denn die abweichung in den
daten könnten auch andere dinge ans
tageslicht bringen beispielsweise die
entdeckung eines besens dass eine neue
physikalische kraft vermittelt wirken
würde sie vor allem auf 1000 weniger auf
millionen oder kaum oder gar nicht auf
elektronen der name des puzzles steht
übrigens jetzt schon fest z
aber auch das wäre ein sensationsfund
wenn ihr diesen fund also ein fund eines
der beiden teilchens nicht verpassen
wollt und unser video dazu dann
abonniert auf jeden fall auch den
englischen kanal dafür einfach hier
klicken
denn manchmal kommen auch da videos
zuerst und darunter geht es weiter mit
sensation etwas köln portal to new kind
of success bin ob ich freue mich wenn
wir uns auch auf dem englischen klicks
um kanal wieder sehen stay tuned co2